on va passer à cette trè histoire
dramatique un jeune de 16 ans tué lors
d'une fête de village euh c'est un truc
de fou ça c'est Thomas he qui a été tué
poignardé dans une BAGAR les fesses sont
déroulé dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche une expédition punitive c'est
dans un petit village de la prêche près
de Valence dans la Drome à
crépole une grande un grand bal un grand
bal dans ce petit village de campagne
tous les tous les les jeunes et un peu
moins jeunes d'ailleurs viennent
s'amuser il y avait longtemps qu'ils
avaient pas organisé un bal l'ambiance
était plutôt festive tout se passait
bien jusqu'à 2h 2h10 du matin au moment
où le bal touche à sa fin il y a une une
arrivée massive d'une dizaine de de de
personnes qui très vite ont voulu
rentrer à l'intérieur de la de la salle
de de bal refoulé par le videur parce
que d'une part parce que c'était fermé
d'autre part parce que c'était une
soirée privée euh une bagarre éclate
entre le videur et ces jeunes qui sont
arrivés euh ça a dégénéré parce que
d'autres se sont emmêlés pour défendre
le videur ils ont sorti des couteaux il
y a une bagarre générale il plantait
qu'un témoin dit ça il plantait à
l'aveugle il tapait des coups de couteau
absolument partout le videur a eu les
doigts sectionné coupé
sectionné et malheureusement dans cette
histoire un jeune Thomas 16 ans a été
mortellement touché par des coups de
couteau alors c'est un diff f
déferlement de violence il a même un
témoin qui dit c'était tellement violent
qu'au début j'ai cru un attentat
terroriste tellement c'était violent
elle a vu les les poignards
effectivement il y avait des très
longues lames j'ai j'ai vu qu'il y avait
une lame de 25 cm donc c'est des des des
vraiment des couteaux pour tuer quoi ils
sont venus pour tuer il y a deux blessés
grave et en tout il y a eu six autres
personnes blessées et 17 personnes
touchées et si le vigile avait pas été
là parce que il s'interpose ça aurait pu
être encore beaucoup plus sanglant comme
bilan c'est déjà dramatique justement
qu'est-ce qu'on sait des agresseurs bah
pour le moment il y a pas énormément de
choses on se dit que peut-être ils ont
été refoulés une première fois qu'ils
sont arrivés ensuite on a parlé aussi
d'un quartier sensible quartier la
monnaie de roman surzer qui est distant
de quelques kilomètres voilà pour le
moment est-ce que c'est une expédition
punitive planifiée est-ce que c'est une
vengeance après avoir été refoulé de la
soirée voilà pour le moment à l'heure où
on parle là il semblerait qu'il se soit
présenté en tout début de soirée ils ont
été déjà vu à ce moment-là avec des
lames de 25 cm et c'est à ce moment-là
qu'on les a refoulé et comme il l'aurait
très très mal pr ils se sont dit on va
revenir en fin de soirée et on le fera à
l'extérieur et c'est là qu'ils ont
attaqué les jeunesition une expédition
puni parle d'une expédition punitive
exactement il y a Hugo un autre jeune
homme qui est à la soirée et
connaissance de Thomas qui a
malheureusement vu tout ce qui s'est
passé il a dit Hugo j'étais vers
l'entrée j'ai vu Thomas se faire planter
un couteau dans le cœur et dans la gorge
un hélico l'a amené mais il y est passé
malheureusement je suis choqué c'était
un collègue à moi on était au collège
ensemble je l'ai vu mourir il y a eu une
bataille entre les agresseurs et ceux
qui ont eu le courage de leur faire face
oui parce que les les autres à
l'intérieur av avaiit pas de couteau
avait pas d'armes ils avaient juste
leurs bras et leur et leurs pieds pour
se défendre contre une horde sauvage
d'une bonne dizaine d'individus armé de
couteau qui était arrivé comme on vient
de le dire une première fois puis une
deuxième fois pour régler régler leur
compte alors il y a un il y a un Chalon
où vivait Thomas les habitants sont sous
le choc comme Aline j'ai failli m
fondrer ce matin je suis totalement
bouleversé c'est inexplicable je le
connaissais très bien c'est pas sont des
gens formidables il n'y avait pas plus
gentil et poli que Thomas toujours à
traverser la rue pour vous dire bonjour
souriant c'est un acte gratuit il n'y a
pas de mot et c'est vrai que c'est un
acte gratuit absolument il avait 16 ans
céit un rugby man tout le monde l'adore
ainsi que sa famille devant le lycée ce
matin c'était l'état de choc absolu donc
voilà c'est on le voit derrière vous là
c'est une mort tragique pour une
expédition punitive c'est dramatique
dramatique sais dire quoi expédition
punitive en fait ça veut dire
ver donc on va dans une soirée on rentre
pas dans la soirée revient avec et on se
dit qu'on revient avec des copains et
voilà est revenu avec des copains parce
qu'il est pas rentré dans la soirée avec
des couteaux ils ont voulu se venger ê
rentré ok j'attends l'enquête alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe non mais
j'attends l'enquête on attend de savoir
parce que ça me paraît juste
complètement aberrant quoi c'est dire
c'est même pas l'ensuvagement de la
société là c'est quand même c'est des
barbares en fait on rentre pas dans une
soirée on arrive avec des lames et on et
on poignarde les gens juste
incroable et c'est très bizarre oui je
précise que tout se passait bien c'était
bon enfant à l'intérieur c'est vraiment
des des gens du du coin qui se
connaissent et qui
s'amusaient sur un bal après après le
covid enfin il y avait tout un tas de
d'événements qui n'avaient pas permis de
réorganiser de bal depuis plusieurs
années donc c'était le premier malall
depuis un petit moment et tout le monde
était content pour l'inant l'enquête il
interpeller personne non non non au
moment où ça le drame s'est passé il
n'interpelle personne et là il tente de
remonter petit à petit de travailler sur
les différentes pistes mais c'est pas si
facile et c'est vrai qu'il y avait 350
jeunes dans la salle des fêtes donc son
entrer là ouais c'est ça et et et ils
sont revenus en voiture à deux bandes et
puis ils ont tapé tout ce qu' pouvait
c'est un tout petit village de 530
habitants donc c'est sidérant en milieu
rural comme ça c'est incroyable je pense
que l'enquête sera effectivement
compliquée mais je pense qu'ils y
arriveront parce que d'abord ils ont été
vu par plein de par plein de gens et pu
c'est le le petit la petite ville roman
suriser romaniser c'est pas non plus
c'est pas Chicago hein c'est sûr c'est
sûr que c'est ils vont ils vont
êtreetrouvés très très vite on espère en
tout cas transfor à la famille euh de de
ce jeune homme on va revenir sur cette
affaire cette deème affaire un sénateur
accusé d'avoir drogué une députée pour
abuser d'elle que s'est-il passé ça
cette histoire elle est incroyable j'y
croyais pas alors
c'est complètement fou euh c'est un un
député de 66 ans non un sénateur pardon
de 66 ans qui est sénateur d'ailleurs
pas un député non c'est un sénateur
sénateur centred- droit Joël guerot il
est âgé de 66 ans il en est à son 3e
mandat il est en Loire Atlantique et euh
mardi dernier il avait invité une
députée là pour le coup Sandrine josau
qui a 45 ans qui est député du MoDem il
avait invité à dîner à son domicile et
début de la soirée c'était plutôt bien
passé
et le le sénateur lui offre une coupe de
champagne qu'elle accepte je précise
qu'ils se connaissent depuis 10 ans
qu'ils sont amis et qu'ils ont une
relation assez suivie mais pas une
relation enfin y il se passe rien de au
niveau sentimental entre ces deux-là je
précise également que Joel guerot est
marié père de CIN enfants d'accord et
donc il l'invite à dîner il lui offre
une coupe de champagne et un quart
d'heure 20 minutes après avoir bu cette
coupe de
champagne cette jeune femme Sandrine
joso se sent pas bien elle a elle se
elle se met à transpirer elle a des
sueurs son cœur se met à battre beaucoup
plus vite une sorte de
taticardie et là elle comprend euh
qu'elle a été droguée et elle se
souvient même avoir vu son ami enfin son
ex-ami maintenant Joël
guerot sortir d'un tiroir de la cuisine
un petit sachet en plastique transparent
et avait un produit blanc à l'intérieur
donc elle l'a pas vu mettre dans le
verre mais en tout cas elle a fait le
rapprochement entre ce ce mouvement et
l'état dans lequel elle se trouve et là
elle a fait preuve d'un sang- froid
incroyable il faut dire que le domicile
de de ce sénateur est assez proche de
l'Assemblée nationale elle part
en très mauvais état à l'Assemblée
nationale elle demande du secours à des
collègues qui étaient encore sur place
qui compte tenu de son état ont prévenu
les secours le SAMU est arrivé elle a
été hospitalisé on a fait des analyses
de sang d'urine et on s'aperçoit qu'elle
avait de l'ctasie dans dans le corps
Chud et à partir de là elle a évidemment
déposé plainte auprès des services de
police c'est le 3è district de police
judiciaire on a on a trouvé les analyses
elle était testé positive à plusieurs
drogues ou étamine opiacé cannabis
cocaïne méthadone
mi c'est le sénateur qui est d'cord
d'accordcord ceux qui
contestent alors lui lui frère cocaï et
d'ailleurs je précise que lorsqu'il a
été interpellé le surlendemain il y a eu
une perquisition évidemment faite à son
domicile on a retrouvé d'as ou alors sa
défense il s'est défendu sa défense est
lunire oui alors c'est absolument
lunaire alors je précise juste cy que la
députée elle se méfia un petit peu parce
qu'au départ il l'invite pour fêter les
sénatoriales voilà et donc elle pense
que c'est au restaurant puis après il
dit non c'est chez moi elle pense qu'il
y a d'autres gens elle arrive elle est
toute seule donc elle se méfie et après
c'est pour ça que très vite elle se dit
il m'a fait ingérer quelque chose sa
défense lui c'est incroyable alors son
avocat dit oui ce jour-là il était pas
bien euh son chat est mort son chat qu'
l'adorait est mort il était pas bien un
de ses amis son meilleur ami lui annonce
qu'il est très malade euh donc il va pas
bien et puis il a une petite coupe de
champagne il se dit je vais prendre un
verre de champagne et et on lui a donné
un produit dit son avocat on lui a donné
un produit un euphorisant il y a
quelques temps il met dans la coupe de
champagne c'est une coupe colorée il met
dans la coupe de champagne puis
finalement il boit pas la coupe il sort
mais il laisse le produit dans une coupe
de champagne et quand la député arrive
il sert le champagne dans la coupe ne se
souvenant pas qu'il y a le produit à
l'intérieur c'est totalement délirant
alors alors il dit il plaide de l'erreur
de
manipulation parce qu'il dit j'ai pas
voulu lui faire ingérer ça je pensais
que c'était un horizon que j'ai mis dans
la coupe et puis l'ai oublié il y a rien
de conscient chez moi voilà pour lui
faire que le ver était mal essuyé de la
veille c'est pour ça qu'il restait des
produits sur le
ver ça paraît plus que léger ça paraî
plus que léger d'accord alors il y a
Gérard Larché qui demande sa démission
le président du Sénat qu'est-ce qui va
se pass retrait il lui a demandé de se
mettre en r RRA m en RRA qu' va se
mettre donc là il y a
la ok très bien donc là sén son patron
ouais est
pH était venu le soutenir lors des
sénatoriales exactement Michel est avec
nous il fa faire le point sur les
affaires et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
révélations incroyables ce weekend
notamment sur l'attentat d'aras on va on
va d'abord commencer par ça après on
viendra sur cette histoire de ce
sénateur qui a été placé en garde à vue
une histoire complètement folle il a été
il est accusé d'avoir drogué une député
cette histoire il fol Michel va nous la
raconter et enfin on évoquera ce drame
ce jeune de 16 ans qui a été tué par une
dizaine de personnes armé au couteau
dans un village dans la Drome c'était
hier d'abord al vraiment les incroyables
révélations sur le tueur d'aras euh il
paraît que lors de son interrogatoire le
lendemainc son attaque mortelle au
couteau qui a coûté la vie à Dominique
Bernard il nargit les policiers oui tout
à fait il a eu pendant ses 96 heures de
garde à vue une attitude de défiance en
permanence ou en quasi
permanence on le voit dire on l'entend
dire vous m'avez manqué non je rigole
euh il imaginait brisé ses menotes comme
dans les films il dit ce serait stylé
quand même compte tenu du crime qu'il
avait commis euh c'était quand même
assez mal venu ces 96 Hees de garde-à
vue ont été ponctué de je vous laisse
deviner des silence aussi où je ne
souhaite pas m'exprimer ou encore il se
mettait à faire une prière coranique
marmonnaé les yeux vers le ciel après il
explique qu'il voulait aller au paradis
donc parce que il essayait donc de faire
de bonnes
actions en étant un bon
musulman fidèle à sa religion qui est
l'Islam et il conclut en disant seul
Dieu décidera si mon acte en fait partie
alors ce qui est il y a un élément qui
est incroyable avant son passage à
l'acte et sur son passage à l'acte c'est
qu'il avait tout prévu tout écrit c'est
ça qui alors il avait absolument tout
préparé tout minuté dans son sac à dos
il y avait quatre feuillets qure
feuillet où tout son projet criminel
était marqué comme un scénario avec les
horaires les horaires de bus également
pour partir au cas où il aurait réussi à
partir il avait marqué aussi les les
heures des sonneries du lycée quand il y
a la récréation et quand les cours
reprennent il avait également projeter
d'acheter un téléphone portable il y a
même le tarif de ce téléphone 129 € euh
voilà en gros il avait tout préparé et
ce probablement depuis des semaines
peut-être même des mois il avait
préparer son geste criminel il il a même
envoyé la Une de Marianne décapité sur
un compte télégram oui alors il a envoyé
deux deux deux deux messages alors on n
pas les les destinataires ça sera a
priori des des des musulmans
Russ ils ont pas été identifiés pour
l'instant en tout envoyé quand même des
vidéos de de décapitation
pasimag de photos une qui représente
char Hebdo et l'autre qui
représente Marianne décapité
effectivement alors lors de son attaque
il blesse au thorax david v un prof de
PS qu'il prend en chasse dans la cour de
récréation et leur échange à ce
moment-là a été révélé je l'interp je
l'interpelle immédiatement lui disant
Mohamed mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce que tu fais sans qu'il me
donne de réponse j'étais obsédé par son
regard noir et froid il a commencé à
parler en ces termes qui te donne l'air
que tu respires qui est le seul Dieu je
lui ai posé la question qu'est-ce que tu
veux Mohamed que je me convertisse je
luii parlé de mes enfants et cetera tout
à fait et il faut préciser que David
l'avait eu comme ce ce ce professeur
l'avait eu comme élève en 6e et en 4e
donc il le connaissait très bien et
quand il le voit arriver avec ses yeux
de fou il a un moment de silidération et
ensuite quand il comprend qu'il est venu
pour en découdre et et pour commettre
l'effet qu'il a commis il a essayé de de
d'intervenir il a été blessé c'est euh
il a pris trois coups de couteau un au
cou un au thorax et un dans le dos alors
euh vous allez voir he il y a les
révélations incroyable notamment dans Le
Parisien